want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's leave
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only brendan burchard
enjoy
here's what the 45
day quit rule is and it's hard for me i
hate this one
i look at all my big project ideas you
know i don't know about you but i have a
journal with all my big ideas in it you
know or i have my vision board or i have
an excel spreadsheet of all these
different ideas and projects i want to
do and i've got like you know right as
an example right now i know my next six
books i'm going to write
i know
i know my next three campaigns i'm going
to launch
i know them
but here's what i have to force myself
to do and i don't like it
i say okay if this is a major project
that i want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if i'm not going to start it listen to
this if i'm not going to start it in the
next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year
and
i push it to 2019. i literally just take
it from my journal
in my little bucket of things i want to
do this year and i put it out into 2019
and i feel
so
mentally relieved
a lot of people have a lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate that they really want to
do
and so what ends up happening is that
anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do they're like oh my god there's so
much to do here so i won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of netflix going oh my
god i have so much to do but i just
watched the fourth video in the third
season has that ever happened
you have so much to and that's the
problem you have so much to do that you
haven't prioritized what you are going
to do so you don't do anything
so what i do is this time of year i look
at all those things that are on my plate
and i get honest
which ones am i going to start in the
next 45 days
and if i'm not going to start the next
45 day
up put it in 2019. now it's not even on
my mental concern it's not on my
dashboard no anxiety there no my god i
still got to get that one in nope it's
gone
that's the 45 day quit rule i encourage
you to challenge yourself to try it be
open
be open
like what's going to attract something
new into our lives is when we have
created the white space around us that a
new energy could enter
right most people they say that they are
open you know well brett i'm open i'm a
liberal or a briton i'm open i'm a this
or i'm open to that no no that's not
what i mean
what i mean by openness
is that
if you think about it like spatially
right like this room what makes this
room open
is the absence
of structure
does that make sense
so in your own life sometimes all that
structure that you're trying to build to
perfect things to organize things to
discipline things to keep everything
great
that structure can also blind you
or prevent
and block out more coming in
so sometimes you need to be okay that
your routine doesn't have to be perfect
that your habits don't have to be exact
that
what your think needs to happen when you
go into that networking experience
doesn't need to happen that dinner out
with the girls doesn't have to go a
specific way
that
you
you in especially in social situations
you structure less
lower your expectation lower your
anticipation and instead go in with a
full openness and trust to that universe
a full openness and trust of faith that
something amazing could come in that you
might not have any control about if you
need help on this go watch that old
movie um what was it called uh
serendipity with john cusack and i can't
remember the the lady's name in that
movie but it was all about like she was
in this she's gonna trust that things
are gonna come back around and it's a
beautiful thing
so you have to trust
that
in your social situations
that things will come into you
be open to that possibility of things
working out here's a simple way to do
that i call it the door frame tag
anytime i walk into a new door in a
social situation that matters to me
right i'm walking in to go meet somebody
new to go to a networking event to go
out with my friends into a bar when i
walk through a door frame i tag i
trigger my mind to say this
what's this going to be like
there's an enthusiasm what's this going
to be like not like i know what i want
now like no what's this going to be like
people who are like what's this going to
be like have higher curiosity thus they
have higher openness and faith and trust
that something is gonna something's cool
is gonna happen
that's gonna draw people into you like
that anticipation that something good
around here is gonna happen that's to
draw people to you okay so that openness
that trust that faith whatever you want
to call it sometimes there's life
circumstances that just kind of shake
you up you know many of you guys know my
story i just
you know i'm here because i had a car
accident
when i was 19 years old
and it knocked some sense into my young
man's head and said hey
life can be incredible you just don't
know how to do it kid
you're gonna have to learn to live
you're gonna have to learn to love
you're gonna have to learn to matter
and i had to learn how to do that
and even if you heard that story before
you probably never heard me say this
part
which is
because i speak all the time and i've
shared that story
literally thousands and thousands of
times
i've had thousands and thousands of
people come up to me after events
and one of the
you know
sad but tragic
and real things that happens sometimes
is people come up and they say
brendan
i hear your car accident story and you
changed your life
i had a car accident
my car accident was worse than yours
or my i had a car accident it was the
same as yours or i had a car accident
and i should have had a realization but
they all say the same thing uh i had
this situation and it didn't change me
why
people ask me that all the time in
interviews why do you think that you had
a car accident changed your life or
you've had these brain injuries or
you've had these traumas and you shifted
from it and other people have that same
experience or even more of a of like a
wake-up call but they don't wake up
why why is it some people have the same
situation and it's a wake-up call to
them and it shifts them and changes and
it actually causes transformation
some sometimes called post traumatic
growth you know
and other people same situation
nothing changes
well they've studied this in psychology
and they've found a lot of interesting
things
that you would say of course well for
some people it mattered it meant
something for some people you know there
was this going on in their life for some
people they were in this age some people
they were you know in in this you know
this mental or emotional state or stage
and unfortunately psychology
usually is not in charge
of long-term development
right most psychology studies are very
short-term and even the long-term ones
aren't
measuring
for
what makes the transformation they're
more conceptual and they're more survey
driven
but
here's what you would find if you
actually coach people and you work with
people over and over and over again you
know what you find
the difference maker isn't the event
how transformative or traumatic or even
the meaning at the event
what changes for people is if after the
queue
right the queue is the triggering event
the situation
after that
if after that
they make
personal development or what we say
self-improvement a way of life
the changes happen the transformation is
sustained or manifested
if we don't make self-improvement a way
of life that means we are consciously
being intentional about our day
we are evaluating ourselves we're being
we're aware
of how we're experiencing life we're
being aware of our thoughts our feelings
emotions we're directing those things
and taking responsibility for those
things a little bit better
we're entering situations and social
situations in ways that are a little
more intentional or a little bit more
graceful or what we'll talk about today
as purposeful i'm consistently asking
like what what's the feeling i want to
have here if you ever see me teach it's
often i always say bring the joy
so i have joy triggers that i've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional about things so for example
a door frame trigger whenever i walk
through a door i say bring the joy
so when i walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that i've set up for myself every
morning in the shower i asked myself
three questions
and not that i shower every morning
the first question i say what can i be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw joy enthusiasm for me
number two i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what might mess me up
what my where might i perform well what
might bother me and number three i say
what can i do to surprise somebody today
to give a gift of appreciation or
acknowledgement today and so i think
through that in the morning so i think
that helps me begin my day pretty clear
then when i sit down before i do work
i literally look at my calendar of the
day this morning and i look at
whatever's going on the day and i think
about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20-minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar
for 20 minutes a day
people think that's crazy
but what i'm thinking through when i'm
looking account i'm like okay i'm gonna
have that call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call
you know i'm gonna have that time with
louis like how do i want to be there and
and how can i make sure i enjoy it
because it's a big deal you know i love
your show i want to do a good job i want
to share something good for the people
you know i have no idea what you're
going to ask
i want to be present for that and and
make sure i i'm i'm really there even
though maybe i have a head cold today
you know it's like that it's like just
thinking through it that first thing we
all want a greater sense of is aliveness
and i always come back to this right
reinvent your life for what well
could you reinvent your mindset your
habits your peer group your work efforts
so you have a greater sense of aliveness
aliveness is that sense of a vibrancy of
being of passion
of presence in spirit in the moment
we all want to feel that the good news
is we can usually get aliveness to
exactly what you know jonathan fields
talks about which is savoring the moment
more
we can feel greater aliveness when we up
our health
right get better physical health to have
more energy we can feel bad
what else do we reinvent towards well we
always talk about another corner of the
the triangle of
being about connection
specifically we want connection with
ourselves in connection with other
people
this usually is about the area of your
life called relationships right
we want to improve deepen our
relationships increase intimacy and
vulnerability just feel more real and
connected with other people
sometimes that changes your
communication approach with your partner
or your spouse
sometimes that changes your partner or
spouse
i'm just teasing you out i don't know
what you need to reinvent but it is a
major area of concern isn't it
another major
part of that triangle is
meaningful pursuits
right a sense of fulfillment or meaning
in
the act of progressing in our lives or
creating in lives or leading in lives or
building in our lives that we want
meaning and fulfillment but specifically
we want meaningful pursuits because some
people have meaningful pursuit they
actually have a lot of meaning in their
life but they're not happy
meaning does not always equal
happiness
it always throws people off i spread it
i have all the reasons in the world to
be happy i have a meaningful life i
don't know why i'm not happier i'm like
oh meaning and happy they're different
things
right what can add on to meaning
to make it more happy
is aliveness and connection but also
pursuit
right we we we are human we love to
chase something we love to build
something to be in progress to be in
motion doing something meaningful
does bring us more happiness right you
can have happiness without everything
being perfectly meaningful
right i can eat a piece of chocolate
with green tea and i'm happy there ain't
nothing meaningful in it it's just a
moment right so you can have happiness
separated from meaning
clearly
but when we are pursuing something that
matters to us and brings fulfillment
that makes a difference
and of course in the middle of that
triangle of aliveness connection and
meaningful pursuits is growth
the sense that we are growing
now i've taught you this growth day
model many times so i won't belabor the
point but i do want to always re-aim us
at those things
because after you know 15 years of
coaching people one-on-one in large
groups there's no question to me that
after we have security and safety in
some level
those are the things we're always
striving for more of
more aliveness more connection more
meaning and more growth if the people
around you tend to be healthy whether
that is emotionally healthy mentally
healthy physically healthy your odds go
way up especially the odds of
conscientious discipline and design
your ability
to
surround yourself
with people who are in a good place
is
one of the great gifts of our life we
are social animals
a lot of what we do in life is memetic
meaning we kind of copy what we see of
others we set expectations on ourselves
of what we see of others a lot of our
behaviors our habits our mental models
are really a fact of sociology
and when you understand that the people
you surround yourself with you talk with
you look at you work out with
you're around you're healthier
i am a greatly healthier person in my
life because of my wife
and for most men out there or those who
are partners in couples where one other
partner is healthier than the other
that's one of the greatest gifts
of all time you know i'm a way healthier
person i don't think i knew what kale
was until i met denise what's kale
what'd you talk about like i had i had
no idea no idea broccoli what what why
wait that's bro how come it's
dark like that i mean
there's no cheese on it
i had no idea
so that was important for me to learn a
lot about and all of my friends in the
health and wellness category like being
around them all the time and seeing
their posts and their instagrams or
being at conferences and studying their
work or going to conferences they're
about health surrounding myself in an
ecosystem has made me healthier
it really has if you look at where i
grew up
to where i am now
i mean it's totally different peer set
and that was by design you might not get
to choose your biology or all your
family but you get to choose your peers
and your friends and the inspirations
who you follow or learn from especially
in this category of health once you have
that energetic vision i promise you'll
surround yourself with better people
when we don't have a vision
for next week
next month
next year
life can start to feel like we're just
in you know kind of in the swamp
and they were just going through the
motions
and oh my god i'm working so hard
brendan or oh my god brent i have all
these reasons to be happy i i already
have the great kids i i have a house i
can afford the car payments i mean i
have all these reasons to be happy but i
don't know something's missing i don't
feel purpose either
it's usually a disconnect
or a lack of clarity
about your future
and i don't mean 10 years out or 50
years out
i mean sometimes next month
and next year
really just sometimes it's just a couple
month horizon
and lacking clarity and connection
with just the next couple months
or in some cases if you're a longer term
strategic kind of guy
the next year or two
i can feel that if i feel a disconnect
for my next year or two
i tend to lose a connection with purpose
a connection with motivation
uh i feel like the intentions or the
productivity of the day
are kind of
like for what
you know it's easy to go i'm working so
hard but for
what and that for what
i know equals vision
what is the vision of your next couple
months or next couple years
no one will give you that
it's time to sit down and think about
that
it's why you all know i keep a battle
board over here on the wall and my
battle board is like it's basically like
a a
arts and crafts version
of a yearly schedule
it's like it's like a big piece of
butcher paper with 12 boxes drawn on it
and the 12 boxes each represents one
month of the year and i create themes
across the boxes i write the major
projects and deadlines up on the boxes
and i write a bunch of my values up
there and all i do is every day i just
kind of stare at it
i'm a person
who is i'm really good any person's here
you're really good at just living in the
moment
i know a lot of people aren't good at
that but i'm really good
at just being here in the moment i've
had to teach myself to do that
i'm not as good
of making sure i'm connected to my
vision
or to a longer term plan
i i'm like i'm like in the moment i'm a
happy-go-lucky kid
but if i lose connection to the vision
to the future
the happiness goes down i also see the
luck tends to go down
when you're disconnected from a vision
so what do i do i force myself every day
when i come into this office
am i like in a home studio here when i
walk in i stare at that
for like and i force myself to stare at
it and think for five minutes i have a
little notepad next to me
and i look at where everything is lining
up over the next year sometimes the next
two years
and i just look at it
i mean if you walked in i mean it's
really not an attractive thing i'm kind
of like this
i'm just standing there kind of dumb
looking just looking at like
hoping something comes into the brain
that day
walking through each month even if i saw
it yesterday
i'm still going i'm just forcing myself
to look out
you know why people tend to be motivated
january 1st
because they're looking out again
and they hadn't done it for a while
today
i get to share some ideas with you on
health that i've learned in my own
personal journey but also as a high
performance coach
for 16 years
you know
one of the fundamental most important
things that we all want in our life
is a sense of vitality
and that vitality is we want to feel you
know mentally engaged alert focused
enthusiastic we want to feel
energetically like physically
energized right physically we want to
feel a sense of that health
and it's one of really the only four
things that we all deeply desire we talk
a lot about it here in growth day that
you can give anybody anything but what
we all really truly want is aliveness
that's what i mean by vibrancy
connection with others and with
ourselves
meaningful pursuits things that we're
doing that we enjoy or see as important
or contributing
and growth
like growing as persons so all of that
is really important but that sense of
aliveness i always put that at the top
of that little diagram
because it's so important to us when we
don't have a sense of aliveness even if
we have amazing relationships
when we are fatigued and wiped out we
can have the greatest marriage or
partner or spouse or intimate
relationship but
the zest isn't there
we can have a great job
we can have incredible opportunities to
serve we can love our passions and our
hobbies but if we're wiped out it
doesn't feel as good
i know you all know this
and that is why it's so important that
we focus on our health
now i want to do full disclaimers with
you i am not a doctor i'm not a
psychiatrist i'm not a neuroscientist i
am not a health advisor coach or medical
professional in any
capacity
i'm a high performance coach this means
i work with people primarily on their
mindset and their habits and their
relationships i recommend everyone get a
coach at some point because
you need someone to have that sounding
board who asks you next time
where you're at in your development
or in your progress or where you're
stunted or whether you're crushing it
and helps you tease out those lessons so
that you stay motivated and clear about
the next steps
and that's why i think it's so powerful
often the biggest shifts in our life
happen when we're accountable sometimes
it happens when you work with a coach or
some of you you become a coach
i've never been more accountable for my
life or had so many other people become
so accountable for their life when they
became a coach because once you're a
coach you're accountable to help someone
grow and you
that instantly raises up your awareness
just like many of you when you get a
teenager and you start talking to your
teenager about health or mindset and you
realize you're a little off it makes you
more accountable because as soon as you
teach it you're even more accountable to
live up to it remember that congruence
thing
it's a beautiful thing the best i ever
became in my life is once i became a
coach because once i was a coach i was
like oh level up your identity brandon
you got to follow through on these
things you have to be congruent on them
too
you can't go out on the stage all the
time tired like come on everybody it's
like i had to learn to take care of my
health that i could literally manage a
38 foot you know stage with thousands of
people and and for multiple days it was
like running a marathon every single day
i had to be accountable to that audience
because i was teaching it it was like oh
as soon as you put yourself in a role
of a leader a coach a mentor a role
model a caregiver as soon as you're in
that space you gain positional
accountability you realize oh
i better walk this talk because if i
don't walk this talk not only will they
notice i will start to dislike myself
i share that
i rarely share the the one of the big
gates that happened for me after my car
accident it wasn't just the car accident
made me want to live love and matter it
was after the car accident i had to sit
with the reality that
i had built the life i didn't
intend to
i had
set in motion that relationship
that wasn't the right relationship
i chose the wrong person
despite some red flags
i allowed abusive language to happen in
a relationship
i allowed
i'd say resentment to carry on
i had done some things
and i'd experienced some things
that i didn't like and i could accept
them
they did
but now
i was accountable for building that next
relationship that had to be better
[Music]
i had to make that next relationship
better it was on me i was the captain of
the ship
the director of the destiny
i was the director behind the movie set
watching that character evolve i was
choosing
the next act that's accountability
that's the great thing to have in life
if you think about the maybe the three
biggest times of your life that you
changed
like those big what they often call in
psychology those inflection points or
those critical incidences
what were the three times when just
major shift happened in your life
i promise there was a major gait to
awareness opened up for you either it
was an insight an aha maybe you're like
eckhart tolle you're just laying in bed
and all of a sudden
you know awareness and presence enters
your life a new level of consciousness
lands on wonderful
maybe you had to go through something
it was a divorce
a business ending
you got fired somebody said no
you got in a health challenge an
accident happened
for me as you know an accident happened
i got in a car wreck
and it was the ultimate perspective
check
at that point in my life
i thought i wanted to die
at that point in my life
i had been suicidal and depressed
at that point in my life i didn't see
that my life could ever be
abundant or happy
or loving
i i didn't get it
and
then that car accident
bam and that was like a knock on the
head literally that opened up my eyes
and made me realize oh i don't want to
die i want to live
i just don't know how
and that was my awareness
it was
i i want to live i don't know how
but i've got this second chance
and i understand i want to live i
understand i want to love i understand i
want to matter but i don't know how and
that began a lifelong journey in
personal development and then psychology
and then philosophy and then
neuroscience and then high performance
studies to try and just understand how
do people change
well maybe as you're listening to what
were those three big things for you
maybe it was a health thing something
happened with your family
maybe you that was when you went off to
school or when you had the birth of your
first child or something happened
and it shifted you into another level of
awareness that said
i want to improve
i want to get better i want to be
healthier i want to be happier and if
you haven't had that yet then let me
knock on the door a little bit and say
hey this is a great time to gain some
greater self-awareness
without greater self-awareness we aren't
resilient we aren't authentically
confident we aren't vibrant we aren't
healthy we aren't able to deal with all
of the chaos without conforming to
everybody else
the moment we lack self-awareness is
when the impulse to conform to everybody
else enters
the moment we lack self-awareness we
don't know how to ask for what we need
in an argument with our partner or
spouse the moment we lack self-awareness
we make a bad decision that we knew
wasn't right for us
it's always the first thing
awareness you want to feel potential you
want to feel a purpose it comes from
acts of service
acts of compassion kindness generosity
with the people around you
are you providing great service
as
a husband a wife a role model a team
leader
service as in servant leadership
service as in generosity
service as in doing a good job with
heart and soul
that's what we mean by service
my
short answer is i hope that a lot of
what you do in life feels like you're
doing it from a generous soulful place
a generous soulful place
if you're a mom and you are generous and
soulful with your kids good job if
you're a leader of a big company and a
mom and you're doing it for a generous
and a soulful place good job
if you're a volunteer and you do it from
a generous and soulful place good job
if you're trying to lead a team
and
you've had the guts to ask how do i do
this well you've probably read about
servant leadership
and robert greenleaf's work
in servant leadership
you go oh okay
the servant
kind of leads from the back
the servant is the guide by the side
not the person pushing with the stick
the servant
has heart and soul
because they have compassion
and empathy
for others
and boy do i think we need to develop
this because we've gone from a
service mindset
and one part of last century to a selfie
narcissistic culture
that has forgot others
and literally passes people struggling
by on the road like they're pieces of
trash and that's where we that's where
we're at as a
society and it's going to be the
volunteers and the leaders
and the servant leaders who are going to
change this world and i hope that's you
and i give you a round of applause if
you are that person who's generous and
showing up for people and giving your
best to your kids and to your team and
your fellow members very few people do
that and that you do that i honor you
and i thank you for that
it's much much needed it's more needed
now
than any time i've ever seen
this moment
that we're experiencing in life the
reason a lot of people are feeling so
lacking in purpose is because there's so
much negativity in the environment
there's so much narcissism in the
environment
we're you know completely bombarded
and scrolling by all these acts
of selfie culture and narcissism
and so few
demonstrations of beauty
of humanity
of genuine
moments where someone takes a beat out
of their day to help somebody or to be
with somebody
and
when you're willing to do that
part of purpose
is sensing
a mission larger than yourself i don't
think there's a more easy access to a
greater sense of purposeful being than
being more intentional
in the relationships we have
but that often happens because one of
two things
either one
we suddenly realize
that the purpose of life is manifested
through our relationships
the purpose of life is manifested
through our relationships you've heard
all the growth day teachers talk about
the research about how it's your
relationships that actually leads to the
highest levels of not only positive
well-being not only life satisfaction
but longevity
the biggest study of the longest living
people on the planet happens to be
completely showing that the the highest
correlation
to life length and positive life like
meaning you lived a good life and you
lived a long life came from people who
had
one or two deep meaningful relationships
and they found purpose in that they
found purpose in their children or they
found purpose with their wife or their
spouse or their partner or their family
there was purpose there and sometimes
purpose in the social realm can really
fill us up
in the self realm
so for those of you who are struggling
with yourself know that maybe deepen
some of those relationships around you
reminder to all of you
if you're struggling in any
relationships in your life
that
is as a growth day pro member when you
click the learn section
and you watch past events under the live
events section
you'll be able to see an entire month's
training
that you can sort by on relationships
and i think that's a really important
call out here we've got and like i
taught relationships for two hours there
jenna kutcher did um koya webb did
anthony trucks did all all eight of our
teachers or so
taught an hour on how they
have learned about relationships from
research or their coaching
or teaching practice and what they do in
their own life to develop those
relationships part of purpose
is sensing a mission
larger than yourself
most people confuse that with
a large achievement
but what it was meant to be
back in the day in these conversations
was it meant you can see beyond yourself
i can see the suffering of others and
want to be of service to them
i can see the suffering of others and
want to be of service to them where that
means your angry child or that means the
neighbor who's struggling or your friend
who just lost her husband
it means i can see beyond myself my
immediate selfish impulsive needs
and i can
be with someone i can sit with someone i
can listen to somebody i can empathize
with somebody
too often we think of service as like
donation
you know did i donate to this cause and
by the way please donate to whatever
cause that you get behind
but
there's different ways to provide
service outside just money
and the biggest part of humanity is
learning to sit with people
and be with them in their times of need
to
let them know you see them
and you hear them
and you're curious about their story
and you want good for them in their
lives
not your way
not imposing your values not pushing the
answer
but literally just honoring them as a
human being our social realm is
incredibly purposeful
most importantly is this and you all
know this as strivers here in growth day
but i think this is so critical
you've got to be around purposeful
people
you got to be around purposeful people
if you feel like the people around you
aren't as purple as they should
send them to growth day.com you know
it's like maybe they need a little
training a lot of people need training
on this topic just like my friend i told
you about the woman i was coaching who
she'd never been trained to ask the
question what would make her feel
fulfilled
most people never been trained on
purpose either
but getting around
striving
giving
generous
kind compassionate high-performing
people will completely make you feel
different about life
i think about my friendships and the
people in my life they got a lot of
purpose
and and it doesn't mean they have this
end game it means they're living
purposeful lives with great intention
and appreciation and presence
so they're awesome to be around
do you have five people who are awesome
to be around in your life
like awesome
and purposeful
if not time to meet them when people
have clarity about their future
and clarity about their purpose it tends
to come in different categories here
okay so let me give you some of those
categories
first
is yourself
i know that sounds like no doubt brandon
but this is
yourself in terms of your identity
this is yourself in terms of who you are
becoming
and this is yourself
in terms of your self worth
okay i'll cover those three elements
here in a second
self in regards to your identity
who am i
self in terms of who you are becoming
who do i believe i am meant to become or
do i desire to become
and self in terms of self-worth
am i
worthy
these questions
make you either feel connected as a
purposeful being
or they make you feel terrible
and so let's explore them
your identity i always ask this in my
seminars if you've never done this work
with me it's from one of my other books
called the charge
the charge being like the amp like the
battery pack like
you know the the subtitle was activating
the 10 human drives that make you feel
alive book is called the charge
and one of the things i started asking
people to do
in high performance work
was
to share with me
to generate and share with me what are
the three words
that would define
the best of who you are
today
like if you had to describe yourself
like let's say you went on speed dating
and you sat down uh
across from someone and the question was
okay share the three best parts of you
in with using one word describe that now
it's kind of like that right it's like
what's the three
like if i had to describe the best of
who i am in three words what would my
three words be
what are your three words
like what are your three
that that is
the best of who you are
or
if you struggle with that the three
words that would describe the best of
who you want to be
i want to make sure
that you have your three words and i
want your three words on a board or i
want the three words on your mirror or i
want the three words next to your
computer and every day you look at those
three words again today i'm going to be
this
at midday am i being this
at the end of the day was i that
we need to develop a purposeful sense of
being
and remind ourselves of it personal
growth and purpose is something to be
cultivated on a very regular basis
otherwise you lose touch with it
just like most people say i lost my
motivation i go you didn't lose your
motivation you lost the practice
of paying attention to the things that
matter to you
and using your mind to rev you up for
those things
that's all
you started going through the motions
and so you lost the motivation you can
still do the same thing but instead of
just going through unconsciously bring
conscious intention
by bringing purposeful being to a thing
it changes
well as you learn to make being a
purposeful being
happen on a more regular basis i promise
you can shift that's the hopeful message
for today i know sometimes you watch
something like this you're not in a good
mood you don't feel good there's been a
tragic travesty something's going on in
the world you don't like and your day is
just kind of like all over the place
but that's why we're here
it's gotta do it's like constantly doing
the work i would love for you to all
type this in either your journal or the
chat or the comments right now i love
constantly doing the work
actually write it down i love constantly
doing work you have to teach yourself i
love constantly doing the work
i get an argument with my wife i'm like
i love constantly doing the work
like you have to keep
generating
the ambition and the engage engagement
and enjoyment
of doing the personal development work
you know i walk out of a conflict or an
argument with somebody and i have to go
recenter myself i'm like okay brendan
chance to learn buddy
what do you got to learn
how can next time be better
how do i really want to show up
how can i repair this
how can we improve the situation next
time
how could i approach it differently what
can i watch for next time to make it
better
let me try
you got this next time brennan
be graceful for today you got this next
time a little more intention okay here
we go
just over and over and over
giving yourself the grace to learn
to
to enter the next situation more
intentionally
that's the stuff of purpose you know
these last couple years
a lot of people stopped dreaming
because we were just kind of trying to
survive
we were trying to deal with and cope
with
all of the drama and the trauma and the
chaos and the uncertainty that came
along
with a pandemic with global economic
shifts with lots of political victory
all around the world we were in this
place of like just like just watching it
was intense
and so when that intensity hits us we
tend to hunker down
and now many of us work remote
we don't see as people as
often as we used to and so we've
constricted our lives in certain ways
and that's caused us sometimes
to be disconnected from a bigger vision
for our lives
and so
i'd love for you to allow ambition you
have you can have ambition in your life
and deep appreciation for the moment
ambition doesn't mean you don't
appreciate your life now and ambition
doesn't mean you become a jerk to run
over people ambition means you have a
great desire for a great future
and that's okay to have again every
day that self-talk commands you to be
congruent with the best of who you are
and the more you are congruent the more
you are fulfilled you can do fulfilling
things but if you are incongruent you
don't feel fulfilled
think about that because your mind your
body your spirit knows
if you're being congruent if you are a
person of integrity living the best life
if the further you are away from that
the harder it is to be fulfilled even if
you're doing fulfilling things like
serving people
so get your self-talk realigned i can't
emphasize anymore how important it is to
master this area of your life
to take control to create a consistent
routine of positive self-talk that
guides you towards being your best
every day
so that you have more opportunities
you're gonna have lots of misses but
because you're stepping at the plate
you'll have more swings you'll have more
opportunities to hit home run you have
more opportunities to have the at-bat to
be your best self and the more that you
do that the more hits you get
the more hits you get the better you
feel the more competent and capable and
so i'm encouraging you all to please
please please remember this
say amazing things to yourself have an
affirmation list have a practice do it a
certain time a certain date certainly in
my world
i you know i i'm blessed to run with the
greatest motivational speakers of our
time
and
all of them all of them
have something they say to themselves
backstage before they go out on stage
do they need to do that
no
yes
if they don't see they're commanding
themselves they're willing themselves
they're encouraging themselves if you
don't like the word command or demand
they're encouraging themselves to get
into the right state of mind to have
their best performance their best
service so that later on they can go
that was really great i appreciate that
i feel good about that i feel fulfilled
see it's hard to feel fulfilled if you
don't feel good about how you showed up
when you feel good about how you show up
again and again and again and again the
senses of meaning and fulfillment
lift up time to
go out and volunteer
my very favorite way to change someone's
life is to turn them into a volunteer i
don't care what they volunteer for but
go volunteer it will change everything
because who does volunteering purposeful
humans you know so it's my favorite way
to improve your social life if you're
not around purposeful people
volunteer
you'll meet more purposeful people more
intentional people more present people
more appreciative people
but also
if you are struggling in any of your
relationships please watch the
relationship trainings or courses in
growth day because they found that just
one
negative or hurtful relationship in your
life
can dramatically decrease your sense of
purpose in life
your overall sense of purpose by one
person
and we know that to be true in your
career right you have one bad boss
they can ruin the whole company for you
well that's true in our personal lives
too
one negative hurtful person consistently
in your life
tends to decrease
your sense
of purpose in life by three points out
of ten
so meaning let's say on a scale of ten
zero to ten you feel life is purposeful
and you're really connected to it ten
you feel totally purposeful totally
connected zero you have none let's say
you're at level seven
having one negative or hurtful person
recurring in your life takes that seven
down to a four
that's why
that's saying
don't suffer fools
is a good one
if you got somebody who's negative or
hurtful
it's time
to do the relationship work to either
improve that situation with that person
help them get assistance or help or
coaching
or exit that situation
if you can't do any of those then you've
got to find a tribe or a community over
here that you build up
that meets those needs
and i think that's important because
sometimes people say well brendan my
mother she's terrible and i hate having
her around i'm like okay well you can't
necessarily replace your mama maybe you
can limit time there
but sometimes people can't they're
they're care-giving as an example
i'm like okay well then outside that
house we've got to develop the
relationships that provide you with that
sense
where it's lacking there in that
particular relationship
and so i think that's really really
important the first big gate of personal
development that i believe everybody
goes through in their own journey to
maturity happiness fulfillment aliveness
connection with others ultimate life
satisfaction
that first gate of awareness
is i'm so the first gate of personal
change is awareness
is awareness
now i know some of you already know this
but think about this
in any given moment we can be aware
of our feelings
of our environment
of how our emotions are affecting our
minds
of our decision-making of our
surroundings
of god of universe of connection to this
very moment
in any given moment awareness can ab and
flow can't it
and sometimes in your life i know some
of you feel this way you're going so
fast there's so much on your plate
you're so busy at home and at work
everything's going 90 miles an hour and
it's like it feels like you're so torn
from happiness or torn from the moment
that you don't feel connected
and that is when awareness is sort of
out the door and that's why in the last
decade the topic of mindfulness
you know went from sort of a a a sort of
a subtle art to like a societal need
and as all of the research has been
showing in the mindfulness research
of how that can make us feel more
grateful happy appreciative loving
connected and kind and resilient it's
become more and more clear that people
get this
but you don't go through the gates of
awareness all the time
by choice
sometimes
it's pushed upon you um i know many of
you have had that story just like i have
in the past where
you weren't ready for change you might
have been resistant to change does
anyone have any family members team
members people in your life who are
resistance to change it's just like
you're around people you're like why
won't my husband change or why won't my
child want to be better or why won't my
kid do better in high school or what
it's like we all know somebody who just
doesn't ever shift into that and what
you need to know i'm going to make you
sort of a casual coach today or an
influencer or a leader today we'll use
all that under the term of influence
today if you want to influence others
you have to understand they're not going
to start taking action to change until
they've gone through the gate of
awareness
and sometimes that gate of awareness you
can inspire it you can role model it and
sometimes
life just has to happen for them we all
know people like that it's not a
judgment sometimes you can't be
responsible for everybody else in their
lives you gotta let life be their
educator please remember
anytime you have
a frustration or conflict or an argument
with another person
please remember
you are dealing
with a trauma survivor
please remember
you are living with a trauma survivor
please remember you are working with
trauma survivors
you yourself have survived traumas and
struggles
unfortunate incidents brutalities
difficulties
awful situations in your life
you survived them you're still here
you're still working through
you're still showing up you're still
working on yourself
if you can put the humanity in the other
person and realize they have also
struggled
and more importantly survive traumas
this will allow you to now be more
compassionate
empathetic
patient and understanding
because raise your hand if you think
sometimes you're in a conflict with your
spouse your partner or someone at work
and they might be acting out from old
triggers and traumas raise your hand
right you think you're fighting about
the vacuum cleaner
they're fighting about something that
happened
in the fifth grade to them
raise your hand if you know what i'm
talking about
the person you're dealing with in that
moment we always teach like freshman in
college about conflict you're not
actually
there in the moment with that person
one of you is probably in high school
or in elementary school
you're in a situation or a moment in
your past that's being triggered to
bring up all these emotions and you're
acting out from the emotion
that's usually unconscious for most
people isn't it true
the more therapy work the more coaching
and more perspective more
self-improvement more healing you do the
more you're aware of those things coming
up
and they will come up as we'll talk
about in my next point
but if it's true that something's come
up for you and it's uncontrollable or
it's upsetting
it's happening for the other person too
i had a great um
uh interaction with the person at work
one time
that i learned a lot
i was
very much i know this is really hard to
understand but i was productivity
brendan you know i was like man i was
getting stuff done it's hard to keep up
with me i am like i'm very i'm like i
schedule it i show up i deliver it i
schedule it i show up i deliver it and i
do it the positive mindset and i'm gonna
make it happen like that was really
really strong in who i was in my 20s
right
and i remember
having this conversation
and uh
well there's no better way to say it i
was
a
kind of a condescending jerk to somebody
at work
i was just was not nice to this person
at work
um early 20s probably
just starting my career in consulting
and a partner at the company saw the
interaction
and she pulled me aside and she asked a
question
that changed my life
she said
brendan
if you knew that person
was dying
how would you handle that situation
i was like
whoa
i mean it was like
immediately like i literally went to
tears immediately the second she saw it
she said that immediately went to tears
it was like
whoa
now let me ask you that think about the
last argument or conflict you had
what if that person was sick
what if that person
was hurt
what if that person was dying
trust me i know i know how the
pessimists
and the people who don't like personal
development would receive this
conversation right now oh brandon here
he goes you know i get it trust me
you're not the first persons i've
trained on this topic oh yeah sure
brendan now i'm supposed to every time i
think about having an argument think of
that they're gonna die sure it's
practical
um
maybe it's not practical maybe it's
and i say that because
there's not a single person you're
talking to who isn't dying
not a one you won't meet a person your
entire life who isn't dying
that's what we call in our work
mortality motivation
when we can see
humans as mortal
when
we can realize it's a short stint for
all of us on this planet
everything can shift a little bit if you
don't feel
this day
it's very likely tomorrow you're gonna
be like i don't feel purpose
and you forgot that feeling the moments
of life
that's presence
is part of purpose
and to feel them even more
you bring an intention to it
right to feel the day you have to have
the intention to feel the day
right intention precedes
feeling
but most people don't know that they
have a feeling then set an
intention i don't like this feeling i'm
going to change
but when you become more conscious you
say oh i'm i'm going to enter this next
situation intentional it asks
what is it that i would love
to experience or make happen
in this next moment
oh i'm gonna go play with the kids or
i'm gonna go teach my kids math
okay
i'm gonna teach my kids math let me not
just show up plop the book down look at
me go what are we doing
but instead
say to yourself okay
i'm about to go teach my kid math
how would i like to do that as a parent
how would i
like to show up
what would i like that learning
experience to feel like between us
father and son
mother and daughter
what what what do i want that to feel
like
even if they don't learn well today
what do i want the end
of our learning session to feel like
for them
what association do i want them to
create
with learning math today
now notice that took me
i think i said i clocked it right just
under 30 seconds to ask those questions
of myself
intentional living doesn't take that
much longer it's like a beat before
going in the situation
you know let me
take a second here
to enter the situation more
intentionally
that is the process of bringing purpose
to a situation
right now i'm using and replacing the
word intention with purpose for a
specific reason because people get all
lost in airy fairyland when they talk
about purpose but ultimately purpose
looks a lot like
daily intention
and the more daily intention you have
research shows the more you say you have
a purposeful life
notice it doesn't say you earn more
built more did more it says the more
daily intention you have
the more you sense your life is
purposeful i always joke that one time
um
i was uh about to kind of go pitch an
idea to somebody who i really admired
and right before i went in the meeting
my phone went off and i had set an alarm
in my phone this was before growth day i
used to just set alarms in my phone now
i just use birthday for reminders
but
i said it and it went off
and one of my words at the time was bold
the truth was i don't think i was that
bold but i was trying to become more
bold like i know it was in me and i know
it's the best of me but it took a lot of
courage to summon like
boldness like
take a big action or ask for a big thing
it happened right this thing the
reminder went off right before i went in
this meeting
and
the in the meeting people started
talking about this big new idea
and usually i would just kind of sit
there and
you know listen and take notes
and i heard them and i heard the
enthusiasm and i loved what they were
talking about and i and i literally put
my hand on the table and it kind of made
a thump
and i said
hey all i'd love to quarterback that
what do you think
that's all i said i'd love to
quarterback that what do you think
everybody kind of looked around the
table one person said you'd like to do
that i said i would they said go for it
and i got like a dream project
if i hadn't got that reminder to be bold
right before the meeting i don't think i
would have ever done that
and that became a very critical in
changing moment in my life
for in terms of my career
and so i share that with you because
there's a sense of purpose
that comes into our life when we are
being who we know we should be
at our best levels
but just like you need a fulfillment
habit
you need a reminder habit about yourself
because who gets down on yourself
sometime
sometimes the words you say about
yourself are terrible
and you're on repeat on terrible words i
want you to have positive words and i
want you to repeat about those it might
take some time i didn't even believe my
three words for the first year i did
this activity
but then i had the blessing one time of
uh sitting down
with oprah
on her porch in my in maui
and it was like i just taught her
and her team about change management and
we were doing this big program together
about your next bold move um
and
i had taught about these three words
and so i asked oprah's three words and
i'll keep that private to her but what's
amazing is when she said them i heard
them i'm like yep yep and yeah
they were all totally true descriptions
of who she was
because she lived in integrity with that
intention of who she wanted to be
it was just like so obvious
and so the beauty there
is
as you develop yourself
as you choose your three words as an
example you choose your identity and you
live into those words on a more
consistent basis you'll be more in touch
with your natural
and best being if you read high
performance habits or you go through
that course
in your app
you will see
that there's a whole chapter on that
that high performers
generate energy
how do they generate energy they protect
their energy
they take pit stops they rest well they
recover intentionally
they don't overwhelm themselves by
setting boundaries
they care
for meditation
exercise diet and sleep
see we know that spirit is beyond body
maybe you all know like you you know
what i'm saying there
like there's a mind-body connection but
there's also a spirit something else
connection
but the truth is
if you have a vibrant spirit
and it's housed
in a 55 gallon drum
of toxins
we got a problem
right
you you you take the most beautiful
imaginable butterfly
and you put it over here
and
drop it in oil
we got a problem
who knows what i'm talking about here
we
have such
positive unlimited expansive gorgeous
godly
souls and spirits
but we drop it
in a container that we keep poisoning
and then
we wonder what's happening why don't i
feel the spirit why don't i feel god why
don't i feel better
because you need
a nap babe
because
you you've been eating
you know
popcorn and wine for 14 nights
because you haven't walked around and i
know i'm preaching the choir growth day
remember you guys are more healthy than
the average cats by leaps and bounds you
all understand exactly what i'm talking
about you are striving for wellness you
are striving for energy but i'm just
going to require and remind you if you
don't feel your spirit alive could you
get some rest
and sometimes
this is also related
to mental fatigue
time to take a break
a few more breaks throughout the day
a few more mental breaks throughout the
day like after i get done with this i'm
gonna go for a walk i have to reset
reset reset
mental breaks so that your spirit can be
creative and thoughtful and expressive
through the containers in which you've
got
through the form in which we experience
and listen i know when you're unhealthy
that's a hard ask
and so that's why also very much
emphasizing meditation or prayer
to get our mind and our thoughts beyond
our immediate feelings or impulses needs
or bodily sensations
and
projecting experiencing or connecting
beyond the body
and sometimes meditation or prayer
are the most expansive
and consistent ways to be able to do
that and so i'll encourage those of you
meditation and prayer or meditation or
prayer just choose one or the other i
think it could completely change your
life reinvigorate your spirit and make
you feel more connected the second we
have to do is to learn to listen longer
and i know you're probably like oh yeah
yeah yeah brandon listen i know i got to
listen no i know but people always say
you know be a better listener i say well
the essence of being a better listener
is to listen longer
see respect is really just a
demonstration of listening a little
longer and i think what we have to do is
train ourselves to be more patient with
people to listen to them without trying
to solve their issue without trying to
input our own story without trying to
figure out the root cause of what's
going on for them i know this as a man
right when i listen to somebody
especially a female and she's she's
upset about something or she's venting
about something or she's complaining
about something or she's just speaking
about something that she's very
frustrated with and it comes at me it's
easy i get i'm like i just want to solve
it i want to stop the noise you know but
that is not a way for me to deepen my
relationships
what we have to do
is allow people to vent at us a little
longer without losing our patients
matter of fact some of my best friends
in the world i tell them the 20-minute
listening challenge when they get home
when their spouse comes up to them and
starts sharing about the day and wants
to talk about a bunch of things i tell
them just weather that storm
for 20 minutes
just listen for 20 minutes
try not to solve anything
try to reflect back what they're saying
or just even be quiet and let them just
go and you know what the funniest thing
is after about 20 minutes almost
everybody runs out of gas
now you say no no i'm ready my partner
can talk for hours and hours and hours
that might be true but usually when they
first connect with you when they first
see it when they haven't seen you they
just there's like 20 minutes of stuff
they want and at the end of 20 minutes
they kind of run out a little bit
they're like oh yeah so so how are you
and that's when you say oh you know what
it was a really crazy day hey would you
mind if i just uh go get settled
just give them the 20 minutes just if
you when you pull up to your house if
you have to you know just sit in the car
center yourself
then go inside the house and let them
get you for 20 minutes just give them 20
minutes give them 20 you can give them
20 minutes you love them give them 20
minutes then get yourself settled
but if i think we can learn to
allow people more time to talk
we start to find greater connections
with people often we just cut them off
often we interrupt them we tell them
what to do and the worst thing we often
do is we say hey you shouldn't feel that
way and here's why or hey why are you
feeling that way and we try to do some
root cause analysis when really we could
just allow them to express themselves
and they'll find their own way so listen
longer the challenge right now the
disconnects and relationships are driven
by mostly distraction today the
inability for people to look eye to eye
to feel each other to sense each other
to be present in the moment and so what
ends up happening when the relationship
goes astray people start trying to quote
show
love to another person so what do they
do they they go out they buy flowers
they go out and they buy diamonds they
go out and they say hey look honey i
emptied the trash hey look honey i
washed your things hey look honey i ran
your errand for you and they're trying
to say look i did something for you
they're trying to show something a gift
to that person to recreate something to
have that love
but all people want to be shown is
attention
and we forget that they don't need
something from you
jesse jackson said a long time ago
people don't want your presence
they want your presence
they don't meaning they don't your gifts
your stuff
they want you
fully engaged fully charged fully
connected with them again if you're
going to improve any relationship all of
the improvement will come from a greater
degree of attention and presence
gifted to that person
to that moment
learn to be vitally there and present
with them again learn to have an entire
dinner without looking at your phone can
you do it learn to have go out for a
walk without bringing your phones go out
and do something together with no phone
no distraction just the two of you to
have a moment together if you don't
think you can do that then you're
addicted and you need to seek digital
help right it's like do not tell me that
you can't have a conversation look i
know you think you're important and we
all think we're really important but let
me tell you there is no person in the
world who cannot learn to have a few
hours where they can be human again
with the people that they love and
that'll be the best gift you can ever
give you want your relationships to be
fiery and zesty and spontaneous again
then those things can only happen in a
moment where you're free from other
distractions where you can be with each
other truly experience something i mean
think about it the the best memories you
probably have in all of your
relationships were times when the two of
you were just kind of in a moment
together where you were truly fully
there vibrantly connected in the moment
present together in one way or another
could be chaos going all around you but
the two of you connected and there was
this feeling of sensors like bam
you know you were there for each other
attention
you have to have the intention to give
extraordinary amounts of attention to
the people that you love by the way this
is so vital because if you don't have
attention think about it all the ills of
relationships come in when people aren't
giving themselves attention anymore
right you can't show respect to somebody
unless you give them attention you can't
pick up on the their nonverbal cues or
or guesstimate or feel or sense or
mirror their emotions their energetic
level you don't know someone is down or
up unless you're attentive to them
so all ills in relationships begin with
giving better more present and vital
attention to the person you love what
you find meaningful and fulfilling tends
to come from
things that you are doing meaningful
pursuits
that you find
intrinsically and deeply interesting
or passionate
or even obsessive
in that you're like i just love this
thing so much
and the more that you love something the
more that you tend to find it to be
fulfilling
and so
we've got to allow ourselves
to pursue our interests and our passions
to the place
of love
that when you have love in your life
you are more
connection with what will make you feel
fulfilled
and it will be in more connection of
what you will later on
ascribe as a meaningful life
never met a person in all my years of
researching personal development reading
all the great biographies being with
psychologists and sociologists and
psychiatrists and being with people in
hospice at the end of their life
never met a single person to talk about
think about write about research or
experience
a meaningful life absent
of love
not a single never done i haven't read a
spiritual text that love wasn't the
center
of
what humankind's meaning is
i've never read any research
that has
found a happy person who didn't have
deep
meaningful connected
and loving relationships
i've never met someone who attained
you know the remarkable status of a
billionaire
or a multi-millionaire or the ceo or the
most successful person or expert in
their field who didn't love
what they were doing
maybe they didn't love it every day and
that's a mistake that every day is
supposed to be perfect and joyous and
abundant and oh my gosh perfect
no
there's lots of days that aren't
but they're on what i would call a
loving path
they're on a loving path they love
what they're doing they might not even
know what the career is
but every time they do that one thing
they feel a connection to it that's
different than other things there's more
interest more passion more depth more
excitement more something there
and we haven't been taught
to pursue those things
especially when we're young
we're taught to pursue avenues that lead
to a specific result that society said
it's good you know we'll do this job
because it leads to that
salary
instead of asking
what
what do you like doing what are you
interested in what draws your passion
what do you love actually spending your
time on integration what does that mean
um i was talking about this with so many
friends so many friends
who have had so many wins
right successes and they don't feel like
a success yet
so good things have happened to
themselves but they have integrated that
they are good
right it's that person who never feels
satisfied who always feels a lack who
never feels high self-worth why
because even though the good things are
happening even though they've made
things happen they've never put their
hand on their heart
and integrated the good things into
their identity
so everything else just bounces off
that if we want meaning and fulfillment
to happen in our lives when meaningful
things happen we have to integrate them
into our life
we have to say ah
that was meaningful and you almost have
to pull it right into your body in your
mind in your heart you have to say
ah
i felt that
you know
it's like i was recently at a wedding
and uh it was funny to see how different
people participate and see and
experience weddings to me it's just like
i'm taking so much of it in and i'm i
wouldn't say because i'm an empath in
any way it's just because i go you know
what this is one this is one time one
day this gets to happen for them let me
enjoy this with them let me bring some
joy to this with them and let's make
this day meaningful people know to do
that make this day meaningful make this
day meaningful on a wedding day or on
christmas or on your birthdays and then
the rest of the day
the rest of the days a year just blur on
by
well
i think that first you have to choose to
make it meaningful that's what we do at
weddings right but then you also have to
stop and feel it and integrate it
i had a great mentor of mine um when she
found out i was getting married
she said brandon here's what i want you
to do
at your wedding on your wedding day
after the ceremony
i want to make sure that you pull aside
your bride denise
three different times
and make a meaningful moment with her
and really
integrate it into your memory and into
your heart
there's one is the best piece of advice
i got ever about
my wedding day
it was like right make a moment
feel it and really integrate take a
moment to pause and and take in life
your newborn is finally starting to walk
those are the moments where you take
that in
and you just pull it in you integrate
that into your life as a meaningful
moment
but a lot of people don't take that same
idea when they have successes in life
good things happen
and so even though they have all the
reasons in the world to be fulfilled
they don't feel full fulfilled because
they've never stacked or integrated all
those good wins they haven't taken a
moment to think about them and to feel
them and to be grateful for them
accountability means you know what my
credit card bills
those are mine i'm accountable for
handling those instead of avoiding them
i am personally responsible
to deal with these even if i didn't
cause all these problems
i am now the person who if i'm gonna
clear the problems off my plate i gotta
take some personal accountability for
that
i am now the person who gets to choose
my attitude today
i am now the person who expects myself
to follow a higher standard and to
follow through
accountability personal responsibility
or personal accountability says
okay
i'm going to own this reality
i'm going to plan my way through it i'm
going to follow through
and i'm going to set up checks and
balances to make sure i do that
where that's setting goals and tracking
and measuring the goals and my own
behavior towards those goals
or getting a coach
sharing socially in the community or
talking with your friends and family and
putting it out there
now your butt's on the line and you got
to do it
i think that's what's important
so often
we say you know
i have dreams
i'm not going to tell anybody
and often in person involved you hear
people say no tell people
because
once you've verbalized it you can
realize it once you've verbalized it and
it's socialized
now there's an expectation you follow
through
here's my question to you
do you have enough expectations
to follow through
often when i work with ceos
as
as their executive coach
what ends up happening is
they have that kind of
maybe they have investors and their
investors expect them to stay on path
maybe they need to hit their quarterly
goals
um but ends up happening
is sometimes they start feeling like
their accountability
is driven by others
and often high performers
feel all these obligations they are
accountable but they're accountable to
obligations that other people have set
and if you want a real fast track to
being demotivated
stop setting
your own plan
stop setting your own accountability
this is why for me as i told you i go in
my plan section of growth day every day
i look at all those plans i'm like
i'm behind on this
but i don't get discouraged i just make
a plan on how to handle it
sometimes i look at him like i don't
like my score here with my friends i i
went three months without really talking
with my friends i don't get down on
myself i make a plan
i don't
fall prey to that victim part of myself
that says but all these other things are
happening and oh my god i just go okay
got it i don't like that i'm the only
one in charge of the ship
you're the only one in charge of those
scores
and once you realize that you're like
okay
i'm accountable what's my plan because
sometimes you've left your
accountability to your boss you left
your accountability to your manager you
left your accountability your spouse you
left your accountability to the kids you
left your accountability to somebody
else and you didn't internally own it
anymore if you've ever been by seminars
before i'll talk about this for a while
and i'll get the whole audience up we'll
play this music we'll do the lights and
all of a sudden we'll have everyone
start shouting i own my dream i own my
dream i own my dream
to help them realize again
they're
the owner of their life
you own your dream you own that impulse
in your heart that says to get better
once you're the ceo of your life
not just a follower
everything shifts for us
and that's accountability if you are
struggling with a sense of purpose today
you are lacking a routine or a practice
to look at your tomorrows
raise your hand if you got that one
if you are struggling with purpose today
you're simply lacking a routine or
practice to look at your tomorrows
i tell everybody you want to be a better
leader you want to be a better parent
you want your day your health together
you want to build a bigger business you
want to earn more money you got to look
at your tomorrows way more consistently
not on january 1 or december 31st
but daily
that's why i force myself to look at a
year calendar every day
because i'm not good at that and i know
that about myself and sometimes when
you're not good about something you need
to create a habit or routine
that you will stick to and find some joy
in so usually before i get to that wall
that battle board i got a cup of green
tea in my hand because i love it
i got a journal next to me because i
love that
i love green tea and i love journaling
i'm not so good at the vision part but i
create the routine just like on email
i've created a routine there that helps
me go through a process that i know i
need to do but i'm not as good at
y'all follow
so this is what i'm suggesting to you if
you're lacking vision we need a practice
to look at your future more often
so critical it's why
when you do that morning mindset prompt
in growth day
one of the questions asks what's a
project i should keep in mind that i'll
be doing in the future
that i might not be able to do today but
i just need to keep it on the dashboard
of my mind
and people always ask well
i
when i do this thing it's kind of the
same thing every day i i gotta you know
i wrote down i'm gonna write a book one
day and i gotta write it again and again
i'm like yes
you have to again and again and again
think about your future even if you're
not doing anything for today
you know even if you're not taking the
action say you have to think about it
you know right now i'm thinking i'm
working on some major media projects
i'm not doing them yet
but i'm thinking about them i take a
moment to think about that project
just trying to get in the unconscious
kind of scrolling around back then to
connect me to the future
because when you feel connected
to the future especially when it's
something that you are choosing to go do
to go build to go manifest
you will feel more purposeful you want
to feel more meaning and fulfillment in
your life think about life more
read some philosophy
read some great biographies of people
who did great things expand your vision
as soon as you expand your vision
there's a different sense of
i would say emotion
and motion in life
expand that vision again
open up that ambition again
now most people don't do that because
well you don't understand brandon i got
disappointed
i failed
they don't believe in me
i'm like and
if you let every disappointment or
failure or discourager out there
pull at your life philosophy and where
you're going in the future
if you forget that you are destined for
greatness by god or you are destined for
goodness by a higher power or if you
don't believe any of that if you forgot
the connection to your own future in
which you want abundance and joy and
amazing things for your family
well then we got pulled into the mud
didn't we you have to learn to practice
presence
practice presence
being here fully in the moment alive
vibrant or at least attentive
right snapping your brain out of that
reactive like uh go with the flow mode
to know and being here
that all this advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow
about being in the moment
there's every spiritual tradition has
taught it as being central to human
happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this
i really believe i i'm i'm stunned when
i hang out with people that they can't
be present for three minutes without
wanting to scroll through something
i mean
they can't be i mean even four or five
minutes they can't do it anymore because
they have trained themselves with
millions of swipes
to be not present
and i believe that meaning and
fulfillment um they become too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and i think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and
pulling that from ourselves there's
plenty of times i mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present i'm like i've trained myself
otherwise i can just be pulled in the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and i have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that blur by
the less sense of meaning or fulfillment
you have
you can be busy
but the days don't blur by
right i'm incredibly busy i'm actually
this last two years i can't believe how
busy we got but during that time
present
forcing myself each day to get present
so i can recognize and appreciate those
little moments
so i can create the connection with
other people
so that i can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that practice
of cultivating presence of i would say
and i know people don't like when i use
this phrase but demanding presence
i demand of myself to be present i
because i know when i'm not i'm like
brendan get present okay so i might
bounce in place take 10 deep breaths
just to reset my brain and my body
and that tended maybe you do it right
now with me just stand up wherever
you're at bounce in place a little bit
take 10 deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life
many people they'll work their whole
career then they'll retire and they'll
retire and they'll finally be like oh
wow look at the color of the trees this
is amazing wow life looks pretty good
and they didn't even see it for five six
years they missed all of it
even though they were amidst all of it
they just missed it you have to teach
yourself to be with it to be here
meaning and fulfillment is so much
as much we can define it and have a
destiny mindset we can feel it
like i i do it for like if i have a
great dinner with denise like things go
great we just have a nice conversation
i'll walk away and i might be like
putting things away and just literally
think in my mind
what a blessing
god i made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here
with my wife what a great
day what amazing moment we just had you
know what years later i'm gonna cherish
that dinner
simple as that
it's what we say to ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
i mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them
be there for them give thanks for them i
believe the more you give thanks for the
moments in your life the more meaning
you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it
that's what presence is it's about
feeling the day more you hear me teach
this now for what 20 years it's like you
have to learn to feel life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drink a bunch of coffee maybe you are
you're you're gonna you're gonna imagine
me uncapping
one day you're just gonna you're gonna
teach yourself to feel the day and feel
the moments more you're gonna observe
more you're gonna breathe more
you have more intention and as you learn
to feel the day when someone says hey
you feel fulfilled about your life
you're like i do
because you are
filling life
with presence
when you fill life with presence you
feel full filled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just going to show up
one day and feel fulfilled you have to
fill the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning
and
really um i would say connection
if you don't do that i promise the days
just blur by and the more they blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and
in that place
you're not
autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to define it
consistently enough
your life matters
my life matters
those people you hate out on the
internet their life matters
that what happens is we get so myopic
into our own world of okay is the little
thing i'm doing today does that matter
does my you know the the this this one
thing i did does that make me feel
fulfilled and complete as a person and
we lack an overall life philosophy
and overall life philosophy
that we have defined our lives and the
context of humanity as meaningful
i know this might be too academic for
some people and that's why i use the
word or the phrase a destiny mindset
if you have lost
that feeling
that says i have an opportunity to make
a difference while i am here you've lost
that connection with what i am calling a
destiny mindset
a destiny mindset and i know some people
will take a destiny mindset that's like
oh you know i got to see myself on a
cover of a magazine i'm like i know less
people on covers of magazines who don't
feel a sense of meaning or fulfillment
in their life
it's not an external thing it's an
internal or intrinsic thing
that
i just feel
called
i feel that my life is leading to
something important i feel honored or
privileged or grateful
that
i can make a difference in the future
and that make a difference in the future
thing
is a overall life philosophy
that is connected to destiny
and i hope you start thinking about that
because you know what sometimes you wake
up in the frigging morning and you pull
this thing out don't you you pull out
your phone in the morning and what do
you do you start scrolling through
everybody else's stuff
everybody else's agenda everybody else's
life and you get trapped into the myopic
looking at that comment and getting sad
or upset about it you get trapped in the
small
things of life the tasks the emails the
responses and all of a sudden you've
been pulled into this tiny little myopic
to-do list
part of your life and you forgot the
being part of your life
you want to feel more meaning in your
life start your day with that destiny
mindset can you show me somewhere
something you look at every day that
opens up your mind and reminds you to
get out of that little myopic brain that
we all have that's just focused right
here
because if you never look at the bigger
vision of life
it's hard to ever feel a deep sense of
meaning or fulfillment i can have a
terrible day and at the end of the day i
can go okay
two years ago here's how i would have
dealt with that terrible day today
how can i improve how i deal with this
terrible day
it doesn't mean you don't have terrible
days anymore does it
it doesn't mean you're not tired it
doesn't mean you don't get stressed
doesn't mean you don't get frustrated
what it means is
you have the intention
to ask
oh
how can i improve how i'm dealing with
this
how can i like what have you ever been
in a relationship where you and your
partner your spouse have the same fight
over and over and over and over and over
and over again it's literally the same
fight over and over and over and over
again no it's literally the same fight
over and over you ever had that
that what's lacking is somebody there is
lacking the accountability and the
consistent action to say how can i
improve this
how can i do it
what's happened is it's turned into a
blame game right
this person's responsible not me
no accountability no action i don't have
to improve it you improve it you broke
it
you cheated you're the bad one you're
the one bringing this up
and all of a sudden you you blame blame
blame no accountability i don't have to
change no action
if both couples get into that that's
where couples therapy has to happen
because they're both in the blame game
they've both taken the accountability
off they believe the lie that you know
relationships have to be 50 50 equal no
relationships actually mean 100 100.
you're 100 you're responsible for
yourself
i'm 100 responsible myself and it takes
100 to keep improving this thing and
making a better year over year
i think that's what people forget
it's not like huge dramatic shifts
always need to happen what has to happen
for most people to change
awareness acceptance and accountability
and then just small consistent actions
to improve
right it's like
it can be that's gonna be so tactical
and tangible i think of like
you know my career as a coach
i
i just try to get better
every session
it doesn't mean i'm always actually
better every session it's my intention
i'm gonna get better
every session with this client will get
better
sometimes it feels like it goes two
steps back
luckily it's three steps forward
at some point
and so i don't
pretend that every day is a bright shiny
happy place i just pretend that every
day it's possible
to improve
to improve my reaction to improve my
energy to improve how i treat this
person to improve how i stay congruent
right it is that constant
desire
that constant intention to have
purposeful living and no one has
purposeful intention or purposeful
living
and decides you know i don't want to
improve today
you can accept yourself and still want
to improve today
right the dalai lama can be fully
accepting
of himself
but he can also want to improve his
meditative practice
right we all have that impulse to grow
improve develop mastery what do you find
meaning
in
is there something you love you could
give a few more hours to is there
someone you love you could give a few
more hours to
is there an interest or hobby a passion
that you just love doing and maybe you
know what it doesn't add up to the bank
account
it doesn't get you on the cover of the
magazines
but it makes life worthwhile
you feel better
you feel a greater sense of fulfillment
from life because you're living life
doing things and being a person that you
love
i think ultimately all meaning and
fulfillment all roads somehow lead back
to this topic of love
might not have all the answers on that
one that might be something for you to
journal about today
how does love connect to your sense
of meaning and fulfillment in life
that might mean you live with love
meaning you are loving-hearted towards
other people it might mean how you treat
other people
it might be the things that you do
it might be your life
philosophy
however you define it i promise you my
friends love
that's the answer somewhere take care of
yourself you know do your meditation
your exercise get a good diet start
sleeping better start learning to sleep
better start taking care of yourself
better physically
and i promise mentally and spiritually
you'll flower
that when you feel good physically
i'm telling you way more likely way more
likely to feel grateful for life way
more likely to sense meaning and flow
and fulfillment of the day so get your
energy up because you know what when
you're wiped out
it's really easy to be pulled into
discouragement
when you're wiped out and someone says
something negative to you it's so easy
to believe them because you don't even
have the mental power for critical
thinking
to talk yourself out of that negative
stuff they just threw at you
and you just you accept what they say
the emotions hit you just don't even
have the energy
to mentally fight back anymore
you got to take care of your health
first and foremost when i talk about
aliveness it always comes from a place
of physical vibrancy and health you've
got to take care of yourself and that
usually is for mental and physical
meditation
exercise good diet great sleep you start
with those things
everything starts to shift everything
starts to shift and i say this all the
time because if you are fatigued all the
time you will be less likely to feel
fulfilled because you're empty
when you're physically empty all the
time how are you going to feel fulfilled
got it you gotta fill your gas tank once
in a while take a break
do more resets throughout the day
breathe again
you know you wanna feel fulfilled sit
and breathe and feel grateful for 10
minutes
simple you know we just got to breathe
again there's a part of reinventing your
life
that really says
i'm worth it
i'm worth having a better future
a part of reinvention that says
i'm capable
no matter what i've been through i am
capable i am stronger than i think i
know i can build and architect the
future i desire
and there's a part of reinvention that
says
it
is
possible
it's possible to change it's possible to
manifest your dreams it's possible to
improve every area of your life even
just small little tweaks it's possible
to have what you desire to be who you
know you can become to manifest a future
where you are happier and healthier and
wealthier and in more love with yourself
and your life it is
possible i'm worthy i'm capable it's
possible you must begin there if there's
any hope for reinventing or changing our
lives because if you don't feel worthy
well that's on you to change
no one's gonna give you a permission
card that says finally hey babe
you're ready
you're worthy you've changed now
no it is an internal reinvention of your
mindset of how you perceive yourself
and that perception of self
what that comes down to being is i'm
going to honor myself and honor the
gifts i've been given and honor this
breath and use the short time on this
planet to enjoy it and to build and
enjoy the life that i truly desire i'm
worthy of that no one has to give me a
permission card i have to open up my
brain and go you know what
dang i'm a good person
i went through a lot of in my life i've
struggled i've fought i'm here and i
still showed up today i'm worthy i
recognize at some point my attitude and
energy in the world was my choice and i
thought if i'm going to bring if i get
to choose over the long term
and in the moment
i want to experience joy
i want to be happy and free and loving
and liked and i'm going to bring that
into each day
i really believe if you want one thing
from today if you could take one thing
as a major intention this year
i would ask for you
to choose to bring the joy every day
it doesn't mean i have to fake it till i
make it it doesn't mean that i don't
have dark dark difficult days and
moments of my life it just means on par
over the average across the days most
often you're gonna get joy from this kid
that's a choice i was not born that way
you have to challenge yourself to go to
the next level whatever that is for you
right
whatever that is for you
what is that please write it down
what is the next level of challenge for
you this year
in your business if you have a business
what's the challenges you're going to
take on
right whether you call that goals
priorities initiatives okrs you know key
performance indicators whatever you call
it those are deliberate challenges you
are setting a step ladder of ever
increasing challenges not because you're
gluten for punishment because in your
heart
you know
there's potential a lot of fulfillment
can feel quote unquote boring
you're doing meaningful things but it
can feel boring if you don't once in a
while have a pop a celebration something
new
that's why you got to shift it up shake
it up change it up once in a while
otherwise it gets stale
even good things and again i tell you
this from a person who spent two decades
working with a lot of nonprofit people
so often they're doing such good work in
the world but if they don't give
themselves a campaign or a fundraiser or
a new initiative once in a while
they'll quit they'll leave they'll get
bored
they won't make their difference anymore
you personally have to shake things up
in your life you
i would some people if every new thing
coming into your life or every new
challenge you're dealing with is coming
from the external
you haven't yet started your personal
growth journey
people on a personal growth journey they
know they have to conscientiously
shift and shape and learn
and build new things try new things push
beyond comfort zones just like keep not
not because they're on this ever
increasing you know demand to succeed
no because they recognize in the middle
of it is growth
they've got to put themselves in
positions to explore the world to learn
more to grow
and that exploration and adventure and
variety and novelty comes from learning
new things trying new things doing new
things being with new people
all of that is what's necessary
all that is what's necessary
you know i think if you think about
aliveness from a perspective of health
you know
what i call you know taking your meds
meditation exercise diet and sleep your
meds right
um
then you think about okay 11 also comes
from adventure and exploration
it's like those two also go together
really well
right
go to a new place
take a new adventure go to that town try
mountain biking try swimming try scuba
diving try go up in a hot air balloon
try running on a new trail try you know
something try to assume try something
new in new places that physically engage
you and all of a sudden life becomes a
little bit more adventurous and when it
becomes a little more adventurous we can
feel the sense of meaning a little bit
more because it shakes us out of the
normal stuff and we can look back to it
and go oh right
yeah
you know the power of exploration has
been
written for
written about you know for over 10 000
years um
and
you know it's that old story
of
the person who has to go on a big
adventure outside of his or her lands
only to come back and dig in the
backyard and find an acre of diamonds
you ever heard that they go seeking for
wealth all around the world and it's not
until they come back home
that they recognize it from a new
viewpoint to remind yourself of how
capable you are because how far you've
come
the childhood you came out
of the trauma and difficulties and
challenges has been thrown in your life
and you're still here still working on
yourself
let's go growth day
you're still striving
good for you
it's possible
it's okay
to desire something great in our lives
it's absolutely okay so please let that
ambition back in as you think about
reinvention you can be centered you can
be happy
and you can still
in that place of being centered and
happy build a great future in fact my
argument would be
you can't do it any other way
until you actually open up a new realm
of appreciation and consciousness right
here in this moment in your real daily
life
you're not going to build the greatest
future you could have
instead you're going to act out of fear
or lack or insecurity and you're going
to build another future that doesn't
have boundaries that isn't healthy that
isn't something that you want
but when you start from a place of being
centered and conscious and happy with
what we have feeling blessed you open up
another realm of brainstorming and a
higher vibration of ambition that allows
you to see a future in which you are
serving with excellence caring for
others living a deeply meaningful life
it all starts with allowing ambition in
saying to ourselves i'm worthy
i am capable and it is possible for me
if you believe that then i know you can
reinvent your life in whatever way is
appropriate meaningful and exciting for
you where does your conscious self-talk
happen each day
see what most people realize like oh
wait i do have time for that but there's
no consistency in what they're saying to
themselves and guess what without
consistent self-talk there is no
consistent
character let me say it again without
consistent self-talk there's no
consistent character
so what brendan
well guess what
if
we
lack congruence in our life
we lack a sense of fulfillment in our
life
when we aren't being congruent with the
person we know we should be
which tends to come from our self-talk
then we never feel fulfilled because we
feel so far away from our ideal
how do you get someone closer to your
ideal you have to start changing the
language they're using in their head for
themselves
and so i want you to have a consistent
self-talk pattern maybe that means for
you you write down an im statement or
you write down a purpose statement or
you write down affirmations that you're
going to use on a consistent basis
over and over and over again most people
don't recognize what they have until
they've left it
or it's been taken away
then they come back or they want it back
and they go
oh my gosh
i love this thing this thing is so
valuable this is so important this is so
meaningful in my life
and i always tell people
don't be that guy
be the person who sees it now
and one of the ways to see it now is to
make sure you're doing new enough things
and then
practicing self-awareness so that you
can have that little compare and
contrast and you recognize
the value of what you have around you
most people have so much more to be
grateful for than they actually are
because they don't even see it it's
right in front of them but until they
leave that context and they come back
then they go oh right
you know it's kind of like when you were
growing up you thought you like you
thought your your parents your family
everything was just crazy and not awful
and then you went to another person's
house that was more crazy and awful and
you came back home he thought
i'm so happy i'm home
you know
it happens in metaphorically in a lot of
parts of our lives right you thought
your job was terrible and then you took
a new job and it was way worse and you
thought oh my god what have i done
right the grass is always greener but
the good news is when we
go through that open gate
and we walk back and forth because we're
trying new things throughout our lives
we can see that the grass is green over
here too
and and over there and we can start
sensing more meaning and fulfillment in
every area of our lives what are the
skills you have to develop for me
that was video for me that was online
marketing including building web pages
starting newsletters sending out
newsletters building opt-in pages to
capture name and emails following up
with sequences automated marketing
sequences i had to learn how to do that
i had to learn how to do webinars and
all these other things not because i
wanted to but i thought am i always
gonna do webinars in my business
probably better learn how to do them
not because i had a passion for it i was
like i'm always gonna do them so let me
figure it out first try it out first do
some research there's plenty of things
online that will help me figure that out
and then after that then i can go into
hiring somebody else because i can
manage it so first piece
develop
the skills
needed to win and if you don't know what
those skills are or those skills don't
currently exist in your calendar meaning
you're developing them then
then you're just going through the
motions you're winging it and frankly
you're risking your career
one of my favorite things to do to check
to see if i got a high performer in the
midst when i talk with people i go what
are the three skills you're working on
right now in developing
and if they don't know it i know they're
amateurs
that's just it there's amateurs they're
beginners and that's not to judge them
that's just to say they haven't stepped
into living what we call the high
performance experience the high
performance experience is all about
developmental goals it's all about
bringing our best and growing into what
we need to your daily g3 journal and
review if you've heard me teach a lot
about down times before especially last
couple years a couple years ago the the
g3 was the three g's and it's what it
means is every single day i want you to
journal on these three
things and i do mean journal meaning you
write it down
in the morning and you review it at
night
so you're that's why it says journal and
review so you write in the morning
and review it all at night and so here's
what the g3 is the first thing you know
is your gratitude
and that is just what are you grateful
for why does that make you feel good
why are you thankful for it and just
write it down in your journal just a
whole like you should have a gratitude
journal already but when you're
disappointed or having setbacks i want
you to do the gratitude in the morning a
lot of graduate journal stuff is it
tonight i want you to move it right up
the morning like just you got to prime
your morning for some goodness so right
off the bat you got to do that okay so
gratitude second major thing i want you
to focus on is your goals
what are the specific daily and weekly
goals you're working on you got to get
really narrow focused
right when you're disappointed or sad or
set back
uh you know
the idea of
creating a vision board and seeing out
10 years from now that's too much what
you need to do is get really close in
your term this day's goals this week's
goals because you can check those
suckers off and get a little progress in
you'll feel differently as we talk about
so goals is important and the third g is
goodness
and the goodness is
noticing what is good from the previous
day
so when you start the day you're like
okay what am i grateful for in general
for life
what are my goals specifically daily and
weekly in each of these different areas
of my life you might have goals in your
career and your health and your finances
and your relationships and then the
goodness is what actually good did
happen yesterday
and that will just get you in a place
where you're like oh this day is going
to be good too
it's making you more mindful to all the
good things and the reason i do that one
last and the difference between
gratitude gratitude's general things
you're grateful for the goodness thing
is to think about what good happened
yesterday and the reason we do that
because in neuroscience we know that
thinking about the goodness from
yesterday
is triggering your hippocampus to kind
of turn on and fire up and if we get
more memory activation off the bat in
the morning we actually have more
creativity in the day too it's weird
sparking memory is good for creativity
creativity is very good for coping and
so that's why i'm trying to get you to
reflect a little bit on something that
happened yesterday just to think through
find that mindful moment and it's also
teaching you to be more mindful through
of the moments each day not just
grateful in general but actually being
mindful for the good moments each day so
i want you to do that journal every
morning and then every night i want you
to look back at it
and
think about it and maybe repeat it if
you want to i just want you to review
the day and review those things
what was i grateful for oh yeah that's
right because maybe at the end of the
day the truth is you haven't moved a lot
forward
maybe you know your your spouse
or yourself you're still sick or maybe
there's still conflict or maybe the
business still because i'm not going to
be paulie anish and say everything
changes in one day and everything's
great just because you did your
gratitude journal you might do that
today it still sucks so reviewing it is
going to put you back in that positive
mindset that's going to help you then
take the next day before you hire a team
i really encourage you
to either hire one person and the two of
you outsource a lot of the tasks so you
learn what that looks like because if
you haven't outsourced tasks before
you're going to be a pretty crappy
manager or leader
right if you just go i'm going to hire a
bunch of people and you get them on
board but you've never actually managed
task assignment and task completion
it gets really hard so what i tell most
people if you're just starting which i
know many of you were in your brands or
businesses or many of you are
solopreneurs and you asked me about this
and he said brandon what if i'm just
hiring my first two people what would
you do i see my first two people i might
first understand your skill sets
i might hire somebody to be your virtual
assistant or somebody to plug one
specific skill set hole that you just
don't have
but then the two of you before you hire
number three four five and six i
actually want the two of you or yourself
to outsource first go to like up work go
to fiverr go to something where you can
put out tasks as projects to people
and manage that
see how that feels
see if you like that see if you find
yourself going i don't really like
working with other people some of you
should never work with another human
being you're just you're horrible you
just should you should just know that
about yourself and accept that about
yourself step into that truth if you
don't want to lead or be around people
you know what you'll find that out
pretty soon as you start outsourcing i
really encourage you in other words
i'm sort of imploring you
take baby steps
baby steps into hiring just baby steps
it it's like when you go to college and
business school they're just like well
start with hiring your team and defining
your culture and having a mission
statement and values and i'm like that's
even fast for most people the worst
thing someone can do is go hire five
people and not even know if they
know what their business is what their
skills should be or if they like
assigning delegating and following up on
tasks
so first outsource and in general
most of the repetitive or simple tasks
that you have in your business you
should look for ways to outsource that
first before you hire internally why
it's just straight up
basics of math
it will always be cheaper to outsource
to contractors
and outsource to people who you have the
ability to hire and fire immediately
because they're work for hire
versus it's somebody who's on your
payroll who who's a team member who you
have to give you know three warnings to
before you let them go and especially if
you're just starting and you don't
really know what the rhythm
there is going to be for them to work
with you
outsourcing is great it helps you find
your tempo it helps you find what you
really do as a business
to outsource so i'd love for you to just
think about and you haven't done this
and you own your business or you lead a
team
to sit down and go okay what are all the
repetitive tasks that happen in my
business
practice
positive projection what that means is
is you should be assuming the best about
your partner and projecting positive
traits and ideas on them assume that
they are doing their best assume that
they are thinking of you assume that
they are trying to do things for you
assume that at least they're not trying
to cause any harm and this is a tough
one especially if you've been in a
relationship a long time because you've
probably already discounted me and this
video just because of that piece of
advice right you say no no no brendan
you don't understand my person is always
a bastard you know my person is always
trying to do this to me they're always
trying to do that to me and me look i
don't know your situation that that
could be true but what we do know from
relationship science and it is a science
and you can study communication you can
study the different ways that people
connect in their intimacy in their
relationships in their marriages and you
see over and over and over again that
often
one partner says something to their
other partner and that person completely
blows it up in their mind with this big
story about how this other person is you
know trying to control them how this
other person is clearly belittling them
is clearly being condescending is
clearly hurting them but when you look
at the transcripts of their conversation
you see that the partner over here
really just said something very
matter-of-factly and this person who's
offended drew all of their past history
or some negative parts of the couple's
history into that conversation and
projected that onto what the person said
in fact often in conflicts the person
who's the most angry can't remember what
the other person even said
they can't recall the exact words they
just said well they made me feel this
way
and the reality is that person didn't
say anything that would from a third
party standpoint cue those emotions
would cue that frustration or that anger
but what we all do is we just take
what's upset us in the past we take our
old patterns our old beliefs our old
hurts and our old pains
and we bring them into our relationship
with somebody and especially in a
conflict now we think that somebody's
trying to hurt us we think that
somebody's belittling us when the facts
of what they said aren't that big of a
deal in other words we blow things out
of proportion because of our past not
necessarily what is being said or
displayed right in front of us
so as a rule the best thing i feel that
we can do in our relationships is to
practice
positive projection
just assume that the other person is
there with you
for you and in love with you
think that you know what they just said
they're not trying to defend you they
just might be in a in a bad place you
know they might be frustrated they might
be tired they might be distracted and
don't get mad at them realize hey you
know what this person is doing the best
they can
i mean imagine if we just project a
little if we gave a little more patience
to those that we loved and we projected
an assumption that they were doing their
best and that they were in love and that
they were with us and that they were
trying i think that if you're in a
relationship that matters a relationship
that's important to you a relationship
you want to stick with you've got to
start assuming better
about your partner you got to give them
credit and the benefit of the doubt
again because you've probably been
projecting all your negative stuff your
own fears your own inadequacies your old
upsets your bad beliefs
into the conversations
and it's tearing you apart
so you gotta figure that one out
practice
positive projection i think
for those of you who are really
struggling to like meet
high quality people from your
perspective
um i can't recommend enough that you get
involved with some local organizations
that are non-profit based
and you start attending more fundraisers
more acts of service and i know some of
you guys i don't i don't have anything i
don't have money to contribute maybe or
i don't have you know i don't know what
i want to do i'm like i don't care
go to a bunch of them and you'll learn
what you like
and i will also say this i know i've
been saying this for years i beat a dead
drama a little bit here
but when you go to a fundraiser
or you go to a volunteer event do you
know who ghost those
like you go to black tie event like a
fundraiser as an example do you know who
goes there
the most successful high achieving
positive wealthy influential people in
that particular community
people who have something to give and in
their spirit in their heart says i i
play this role in this community where
i'm going to make a difference here
awesome
i mean some of my best friends i've met
throughout the years i met either doing
the work of contribution or literally on
a non-profit board
or at a fundraiser
because that striving community who
wants to make a difference
i can't i can't share with them but
here's the thing
whether you go do that or you don't
the people who are closest to you if you
want to make a difference with them
if you want to deepen that relationship
find a way to make a difference together
go do something cool
that contributes go volunteer i think if
you really want the closest friendships
imaginable
you go volunteer once a month or once a
quarter
you just
you don't wait for you schedule it i
want you to be the friend that schedules
the contribution
be that friend
don't hope that person comes into your
life you're that scheduler
you're that person who sets that up
you're the person that gets them
together because at some point they'll
take it over in all of my greatest
friendship circles
i tend to be the person who initiates it
and we do something and then sometimes
i'll do it next time i'm like great
just do that
acts of contribution to god just try
and what i mean by try is try with other
people again
i i watch people talk at lunch they're
not really trying to be engaged they're
not really there they just and it's
great that they're comfortable with
themselves but they kind of they're
going through the motions
and very few things ever happen amazing
when people are two people are just
going through the motions because our
default going through the motions unless
it's imbued by like challenge or
presence or vibrancy usually our default
is homeostasis of just like
yeah
and that is not very attractive okay
that is not something gets people's
attention when people get people's
attention is when you put an effort to
listen to them to be with them to be
present with them to change the energy
between the two of you for you to spark
something stop waiting for good energy
to come into your life and start
generating great energy and you feel the
difference try with your energy again
right really pay attention to people be
present with them they'll feel that
you're trying and they'll appreciate it
i'm not saying faking
right so it's not authentic and real
don't do it but you must try more often
to show up as your best self into
conversations and to try and pull out
the best of others i think the most sexy
thing in a person ever is someone who's
trying to pull out the best energy from
you right whether they're trying to pull
out the flirtation of you or pull out
the joy of you or the gratitude of you
or that positive range of emotions from
you that's pretty sexy so try to bring
out the best of others
you have to adore people
if you don't adore the person that you
are with right now you have to re-summon
that up you have to look for the things
in them that will help you do that and
the way they do that give them more
attention
show them more appreciation when they
receive more attention and more
appreciation from you
there will be an energetic change in the
relationship it will turn more vibrant
more there'll be more pop in it and all
of a sudden you'll start to notice that
person they come a little more alive
around you and it'll be easier to adore
them because you're like oh look i never
even noticed they do these things that's
funny or oh gosh i never noticed they
did all these things for me i have
attention to that now and i appreciate
that now you'll start to adore them more
when you adore the person with you with
more you do things for them you do more
things for them you want to see them
light up you start supporting their
dreams more how are you doing that
because real adoration
is getting out of your own way and
asking what is it about this person's
life that i can support that they love
to do because showing real adoration is
showing support
real adoration is not just doting on
somebody with flowers and gifts though
you should do that too it's about
wanting to support their bigger life
goals their bigger dreams when you truly
adore somebody you want so desperately
to see them happy and passionate engaged
living their own fully charged life when
you really adore someone you go out of
your way out of your way to brag about
them in front of them right when they're
there and you're in a social situation
you'll you'll you'll compliment them
you'll you'll brag about them and you'll
make them like if you haven't made your
partner your spouse your lover your
husband your wife blush for a while with
a good compliment in front of other
people what are you doing right i'm
always trying to embarrass my poor lady
you know and but in a positive way
because i'll compliment her in front of
other people and she'll she's like i
really appreciate you said that about me
because i want her to feel adored i want
everybody in the community i want
everybody in my life to know how much i
adore my lady so do you have that
intention for yours for the person
you're true with does everybody know how
much you adore them are you bragging
them up are you really adoring them
personally and publicly when you do that
you'll notice a different level of
engagement in that relationship too and
everything will change because they will
feel adored appreciated and feel like
you're giving them attention so they'll
turn it around now they give you more
attention more appreciation more
adoration adoration and there'll be this
spark and it happens between the two of
you that you never imagined that you
could have that is what it feels like to
live the charge life literally today
somebody a friend of mine reached out
about a situation going on in the world
that he wanted to support and was asking
me for support
and it was a cause i don't know that
much about
but i know he loves this and this is
near and dear to his heart
and i can learn from it and so i support
it
i think of all the time like what what
is my wife love oh she loves that you
know that thing she loves design she
loves that show she loves these people
she loves this experience okay okay how
can i serve that up because if you serve
up what other people love or you honor
it respect it cheer it on support it in
some way
the depth of that relationship becomes
tangible and now there's energy there
because they feel
the three things that everybody needs to
feel they feel understood they feel
validated they feel celebrated to live
their own life
so if you can understand other people
if you can validate them if you can
celebrate what they like and what they
love their obsessions
versus making them have to do what you
do
life is so much easier
i'll tell you an example uh years ago
denise and i started working together
and uh we had a podcast at the time hvx
podcast i think we did maybe like 10
20 episodes maybe i can't remember what
it was and it was just super clear
that this was not something that she
loved
and we didn't love doing it really
together the way that we thought we
would it was like
let's call that
so we just ended it
didn't worry about what people thought
didn't worry about the business didn't
worry i was like oh that's not something
we love doing together let's not do that
there's things that i love in my life
totally not her jam things that she
loves totally not my jam
but we cheer it on
we support it and it creates that depth
and that closeness of relationship and
if you don't have that with other people
guess what
you don't get to complain
it's your job to have that difficult
conversation it's your job to bring it
up to make a plan to work through it
even if that takes weeks or years
to shift
your mutual behaviors in that
relationship don't give up on the person
just because they don't get you
because guess what it's not their job to
get you it's not your job to get you but
if you want to have a graceful deep
intimate connected relationship it's now
time what do they love and how can i
support that how can i let them be their
thing let them you know fly their flag
be their weirdness and cheer them on in
whatever way that makes sense because it
makes them happy
what does your spouse your partner your
co-workers love to do
you know uh in my companies i never am
like you have to be this role i'm like
what do you like to do first always like
what what do you like well i don't like
this i want to do that i'm like oh well
let's try to figure out a plan to get
you more towards that
and that's always been my thing oh you
like that you want to do more of that
okay
and that makes a team feel heard and
seen and recognized and if they complain
and they don't like something they're
just like oh can i shift that for them
because that's their vibe
you got to figure that out i do not
expect other people to think or feel
or experience life
like me
it just isn't there i don't think my
team members should think like me or are
like me i don't think that my spouse is
anything like me she has her own
universe of emotions and feelings are
very different than mine trust me way
different
i we think i think my family my friends
is like there's no
for me
uh demand
that
they think like me it doesn't mean i
don't get frustrated that we don't have
a good relationship or i don't like
their communication or i don't like
something they said or i feel neglected
or hurt we all have those things the
question is
over a period of time
do you have depth and closeness in that
relationship
i promise there's a ton of things
denise my spouse she would say that she
doesn't like about how i think or how i
experience the world
and i would say the same about her
but the question isn't do we like
everything that we say the question is
is there depth and closeness and
intimacy in our relationship
and that only happens if enough times
you realize the person is different than
you
different preferences
different hopes different needs
like i'm i'm probably needier than my
wife is
in terms of like emotional stuff and
just the way i am
and you might be different than your
spouse your friend your dad your mom
someone who raised you
and if you're trying to cram the world
with this expectation that they gotta be
think and behave exactly like you
that is where there is a ripping of that
relationship
you gotta let other people have their
own life
and the more you try to control their
life the more misery you have
a lot of mental health is letting other
people
live their life
not trying to control everything
you know what mental illness is when you
feel like you must control everything i
think it's really important to
stay in your job in a relationship and i
don't mean my your employment right you
can quit your job but don't quit the
relationship but what's your job in a
relationship it's to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or empty the garbage or
take out the dishes wait i think i got
it backwards but they forgot something
and we get mad at them we forget our job
there is to love
and if you're really going to choose
love over choosing your past or you're
going to choose love over fear or hurt
or pain or choose love or being you know
right
then you're going to start to find
something switches in that relationship
and it's a good thing see most people
aren't choosing love they're choosing
fear most people aren't choosing love
they're choosing hurt and because of
that over and over and over again that
simple choice in the relationship
they're not approaching the relationship
with the intention of love
right if you can approach your
relationship with the intention of love
to say look i'm just going to keep
bringing joy and love and acceptance and
compassion and empathy and vibrancy and
sensuality to this relationship and
you're always doing that more often than
you're bringing negative stuff that
relationship will suddenly start to turn
positive it will get easier as you
change your intentions to be more geared
towards love that's your job stay in
your job in the relationship to love
this person to make their day to
surprise them to care for them stop
asking so much what you're getting from
the relationship and how they've done
you all wrong and start asking what have
you been doing right what have you been
doing to add value love energy vibrancy
sensuality to their life what have you
been doing to love them ask the question
how can you deliver more love to your
partner and to the world and you might
start to experience what we call
the charged life if you know
you're a person of excellence and if
it's true
i would not see a rhythm of crashing and
burning i would not see a rhythm
of burns and busts
burning out
failures
and exhaustion
and it's really hard because i know
trust me i like there's so many nights
i'm like oh my god
if i just stay awake for four more hours
i can get these projects done and you
know what and then i'm a complete idiot
72 hours later i know it will catch up
with me
those who play the long game don't
compromise in the short game because
they know it catches up later and that
catch-up is a devil it is a bear it is a
beast it knocks you down and what
happens is you i'll compromise three
hours here
but then because that compromise three
hours here
you're knocked off your feet three days
over here
so if you'd taken the three hours to
recharge you wouldn't be worthless for
three days in the middle of the week
right i want you to have steady rhythm
that's what we call high performance
that ability of long-term success while
maintaining your well-being
and your health my friends you so
deserve that double down on your
goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 20 20 you want to find
purpose this year double down on your
goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can i be a role model how can i serve
how can i do more good in the world
because as i do more good in the world i
lift the world as i do more good in the
world it challenges me to be a person of
potential and as i challenge myself to
be a person of potential and i inspire
other people i feel like i am
serving a purpose
see when we send some role models to
others
purpose is connected in that very moment
when you know you're being a role model
your kids boom purpose is connected when
you know you're being a role model for
your team boom purpose is connected when
you're standing on stage and you're
speaking your truth boom purpose is
connected you don't have to go hope to
find it it's connected when you are
being
a role model it's connected when you are
activating your full potential it's
connected when you are in alignment with
your truth
you got it you have to go look for it
you need to connect to it let me review
where my week went good and bad
and let me decouple my emotions from
that so i can enter monday with freedom
because when i am in a space of freedom
i make much better decisions than when i
am in the space of lack when i am in the
space of self-hatred when i am in the
space of carrying all this stuff
unprocessed i mean have we learned
anything from personal development other
than hey you got to process the stuff
that went
that happened in your life and
understand how you identify with that
and what you're going to do next you got
to process it man and most people
because they're not processing
their immediate snap judgments of self i
screwed up
imagine if we could just loop back your
last couple months
and every single week just think about
every think about how much you screwed
up the last couple months i don't know
about you but mine's like a like like my
hands would have like i can't i don't
have enough hands like to count the
number of screw-ups in the last couple
months i can't it's like it's so
infinite number of screw-ups but imagine
if every time i screw up i'm like oh
you're screw-up ugh you're dumb brendan
and my self-talk in that moment was snap
judgment which most people it is snap
judge and self-talk dummy oh
i know this stupid brendan
imagine if we take a loop of that for
the last six months
uninterrupted unpaused unedited and we
took out all the situations of life we
removed all context and it just sounded
like screw up you suck you suck you suck
why'd you do that oh my god dummy dummy
dummy stupid stupid stupid stupid and we
didn't
de-hook that
we didn't decouple that
that's what most people's realities are
and because that's always running
unconsciously because they're not
deliberate processing
they're not living a courageous life now
because every time they think of
courageous thought
that overwhelming chorus of noise
filters and swamps and smashes
that that whisper of a dream that is
bold
is beaten to death by the rap base
of the horrid
talk that we have with each other it's
like
in the back right
and so that noise
needs to be
synthesized and edited down
on a simple sunday
you just sit there on your sunday and
you go
all right man
i had a lot of noise this last week
a lot of things didn't go the way i did
but you know what let me think about
them how could i have met those
situations as my highest self or more
courageous self what could i have done
okay good good brendan you're learning
good job brennan you're learning oh yeah
you could have been better than
yeah good for you having the intention
to be better good for you to learn
brendan good for you to set higher
intentions brennan good job being on
purpose good job brendan trying to
improve your life okay good job you
really
you got a new way to look at that
brennan good job
now just
let it go man
just take that emotion and let that
emotion float away for a little bit
don't let that emotion from that mess up
mess up my monday
it's sunday
i gotta let that go
i forgive myself in that situation
because i've learned i forgive the other
people in the situation because even if
they didn't learn i learned and they
gave me a lesson
i let go of that situation because that
situation is not in this moment as i'm
sitting here with my green tea and my
journal reflecting on last week in this
moment i got a journal i got a green tea
it's just me and the green tea
so you see we've got this opportunity to
make a space
every week in which we debrief the weak
and decouple ourselves unhitch the
trailer of weight
and let it fall back down the hill if
i'm having
some dark days and sad times i'm like i
gotta get progress so what i'll do is
i'll identify my five major moves if you
read this book high performance habits
you know about the five major moves so
identify my five major moves and i'm
like i'll swiftly move towards one
because momentum can shift mindset
and so if i'm a dark disappointment down
momentum like achieve some goals but
here's what's important notice i said
the five major moves
that's what i mean with progress because
what a lot of people mistakenly do is
they just start doing lots of tasks and
activities that aren't correlated in any
way to the meaningful pursuits of life
so here's what happened
i'm bummed i'm downed so i'm doing a
bunch of work
the next day they still feel bummed and
down
because what was their work it was a
bunch of activities that actually didn't
matter that didn't give them any meaning
so if you're down
the most important working you'll be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection enthusiasm meaning
fulfillment satisfaction from those ones
that do intrinsically bring you joy
those are the ones that i want you to
progress towards matter of fact i really
want you when you're feeling down
disappointed major setbacks dark days
what i really desperately want you to do
is stop multitasking and doing all the
little like busy work things that don't
matter
like
like put off like if if it's wednesday
and
you know you got a stack of bills and
they're not due
for another
30 days
don't pay the bills that day because
that's not fun and you're you've got
plenty of time to do it later when you
fee like when you get over this piece
that's funk like just say okay write the
date on those bills pay them on but
don't do it today
because that's busy work instead today
find an activity that you find to be
creative compelling engaging fulfilling
and do that progress towards the things
that have meaning that's huge
when you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food
is doing low hanging fruit activity
i'll pay the bills and answer a bunch of
emails you know but those small little
tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it and
there's a big misconception about that
in the culture including the science
that often says oh no no just you know
if people can complete small steps
small tasks
they'll feel better
and it's like
well yeah i mean we all have this reward
system in our brain and little dopamine
will fall out but do we do we want a
little
drip drip of dopamine or do we want the
floodgates to come open and feel alive
so i want you to do the activities that
are more meaningful
not just like tasks
you know
it's really important you've got
to start
creating meaningful moments in your life
what do you mean by that well listen you
and i both know i mean how many times
you get caught up in the day you get
caught up in the news you kind of when
you're you're you know swiping and
looking and looking and consuming you
get caught up in your to-do list you get
caught up in all the emails you get
caught up in all the work and all of a
sudden the whole day went by
and you didn't feel it
and i'm here to tell you something that
really remarkable that i've learned this
last year uh you know last year was my
first year where as a high performance
coach i was coaching two billionaires
and i'd never done that before i mean i
mean many of you guys know and you've
been with me on my journey you know for
what uh
two decades i've been in personal
development and in this last decade it's
kind of where i made my mark you know i
published six books uh we grew our
audience to you know whatever five
million on facebook and you know 800 000
whatever it is on instagram now 800 000
on youtube uh best-selling books
traveling you've seen us fill the rooms
and all the events that i do
but this last year was like a whole
other level for me it was so hard so
challenging we we moved denise and i and
i also started taking on these caliber
of clients i mean holy cow i didn't know
i didn't know if i could handle it i
mean i'm not a billionaire i got no
problem telling anybody that i'm not out
there trying to pretend i you know
pretend uh you can't fake it with
billionaires they know
and
so when i was coaching them i kind of
struggled for a while to
figure out what they were unhappy about
i hope that doesn't sound flippant but i
was like
wow they got so much going for what
what's up why why aren't you happier if
you have everything right
like the material things most people are
seeking why aren't you happier and i'll
ask you guys that same thing
why do you feel like you're not happier
like
what's going on
i mean
most people consumer watching this i
mean you're doing okay
i mean you might be unhappy here and
there you you might struggle with like
especially i mean a tremendous amount of
our audience and in personal development
is strivers they're achievers they're
working hard they're often the leaders
in their community and everybody goes
wow they're already impressed with you
they're already happy that you're
chasing your dream they're already like
kind of like you're living your own
you're living life on your own terms a
little bit and so were these major
people i was coaching i couldn't figure
out what's going on with them and then i
finally i tripped on maybe
it was last year the end of i think was
the end of the prior year
i got it
here they were doing amazing things guys
every single day
they were living the dream they had
finances they they had impact they you
know people were impressed with them
they uh you know had love often in their
life they were married or had good kids
or whatever
but they still weren't happy and they
still did not feel connected
and here is what i discovered
they did not
feel
the day
we say it again they didn't
feel
the day
they went through the day some of them
very high achieving through the day
accomplishing things on their purpose
making a difference a role model earning
doing the whole thing and yet when they
laid their head on the pillow at night
they hadn't felt
the day
think about that for a moment think
about how many days you go to bed and
you didn't really feel
the moments of the day
and this is why too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect with purpose
too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect
with purpose
does that make sense
and so what we what do we have to do we
have to create the habits the routines
the patterns where we learn to create
and feel meaningful moments
it's i talk about this in my book the
motivation manifesto or you guys hear me
talk about on the brendan show a lot my
podcast where you you have to take
these moments in time and do what i call
slow time
it's like yes you're going to kiss your
honey on the way out the door to work
but you know what when you plant that
kiss plant that kiss baby i like make it
a moment feel that moment
you know
when you hug the kids and they run off
to school like really give a real hug
don't like paseo and move on to the next
thing we're always moving on to the next
thing and not feeling this moment
we're not present in the moment
because we're not thinking about let me
create something meaningful let me feel
something here because we're absent of
presence
and the sense of meaning in the moment
we are disconnected from purpose
you need to know what moves the needle
in your business and hire to that
not just what you like
you need to know what skills are
necessary for your future and develop
that not just what you're naturally good
at and this is where people fail all the
time
they're just trying to play in their own
lane
but once you step into the role
of a business owner or you step into the
role of leader
it's no longer about just your passions
you have a responsibility it's called
stewardship you have stewardship to your
team
to their mortgages to their rent you
have stewardship to your company now you
have stewardship to the future you
really have to step into the identity of
ceo
even if that's not what you're about but
i've learned so long working with
entrepreneurs some of them just never
step into the identity they need to
assume to win
they never stepped into i'm the ceo now
i'm in charge
so they're kind of half it they kind of
like hobby it they're not really in that
role where they have defined this is who
i am i'm in charge of building this if i
don't it all falls apart and take it
upon themselves to say i have to lead
here well i have to do well here because
if they don't do that
guess what
no one else is going to do it for them
if the only challenges you're facing in
life right now are the ones that life
threw at you
that's why you're unhappy you're only in
reacting mode you're not in growing mode
let me say it again
you're in reacting mode
not growing mode
you're going through the motions and
even if you're congruent you're being a
good person you're you're showing up
trying each day to be yourself be your
best
but if you still feel unfulfilled
if you still feel like you haven't
broken through that's a good higher
calling to honor that is saying to you
challenge yourself young man
challenge yourself young woman
challenge yourself my friend it is time
to rise to the next level the world the
universe god your soul your spirit is
demanding more of you rise to the next
level
that is a beautiful impulse we must hear
and if we don't hear it it's because
we've drowned it with negative thinking
and the wrong intentions so we must now
challenge ourselves 2020 this 2022 this
year this is a year for you of
challenging yourself
and not getting discouraged do you know
who feel
incredible meaning in their lives
people who cherish
their life
cherish it
truly
cherish
their life
and if you feel like i'm speaking
philosophically to you i'm not
i've had the
both the blessing and the very
real difficulties of being with a lot of
people at the end of the life
and many of you know i've volunteered in
hospice i've been with my own father as
he passed away
um
in our home
and
i can share with you
that
it's not until too late that many people
finally start cherishing
their life
really owning
and appreciating different parts of
their life
and if you can remember to do that
i think something magical happens
that's why i ask everybody go into your
growth day journal every day and capture
any meaningful moment capture any
sense of gratitude capture any event you
didn't like and spin that meaning into
such a way where you acknowledge what's
real but you're back in control of your
emotions feelings and your next actions
it's like by the more often that we
capture moments that we can cherish or
moments that we can learn the more life
becomes more meaningful but absent of
that self-reflection it's just a busy
blur
that's why journaling has proven over
and over and over in psychology
including mental health practices and
yes therapy to dramatically shift
people's thoughts and feelings and life
satisfaction over the long term
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one with les brown check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you're marching
toward purpose
meaning
and impact
whatever
vision that you hold for yourself see it
accomplish
and understand this